[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we're very
very careful boys i'd like to be oh
carefully so today we're going to talk
about the last time that we cried oh
[ __ ] who's going to go first it takes a
real man by the way i cry a lot i think
but not like i'm not to the point where
i'm like you know like all in but i do
get teary-eyed over a lot of people like
what
like recently don't say movie [ __ ] cuz i
always cry movies oh not a movie okay
all right that's hard that's hard yeah
movies like dog videos real [ __ ]
[ __ ] you real life bro i think i i
always cry on the airplane really but
movies
that's why
but then before that you're sucked in
for some reason yeah and then like the
air and the lack of oxygen or whatever
it is it's just [ __ ] tears fall out
dude yeah for stupid reason that doesn't
count sorry i gotta say that there's a
very strong movie moment that didn't
make you cry that i wouldn't mind
sharing with you guys i cry in every
movie i was on an airplane
right and uh i remember i was sitting in
front of uh vein was on the same flight
on my crew ving and his wife gabby right
and i'm sitting between two super big
fat guys too right and then i turned
around one point in the movie it the
international flight i look back and
they're both bawling
i'm like what the [ __ ] right they're
like dude you gotta watch this movie the
line
lion lion oh that movie's so good bro i
cried on that [ __ ] moment to go like
dude like they no they were just crying
and i turned around and i was like
cracking up because you know anytime you
see your home you cry no matter what it
is oh you knew them do they do they wipe
their tears are they shaved like no
they're not ashamed at all they're just
for but they are wiping they're just
like oh my god and they're like you
gotta watch this movie line and i was
like dude i'm not gonna [ __ ] watch a
sad movie by myself if you're between
these two huge dudes and just cry myself
right so i'm like [ __ ] i'm not
watching that movie so good i'm not
watching that [ __ ] so i put on another
movie
the movie ends up being a movie called
the monster calls a month who's in that
uh i don't remember the kid's
name but it's it ends up being uh rosie
perez yeah it ends up being this kid in
this movie where um he
like uh something about like his is one
of his parents committed suicide or
something like that
right and so the way that he wanted to
cope with it is he retreats into his
imagination so there's this like giant
monster in it and stuff like that that
kind of like
walks and i've heard about this movie it
ends up being a super really really sad
thing next thing you know i'm [ __ ]
bawling on this plane by myself between
these two huge dudes
and it's like yo yo i look around i
turned back to them like did you wash
line i'm like no
that's another one
i was watching rumble in the bronx
the bottle part where the glasses will
shut yeah
and meanwhile the monster was like it
was in so much pain i didn't do anything
and then the mom and the monster movie
the monster was like how long
but but i will say i've noticed that
you son of a [ __ ] notice this about
myself and i think it's a i think it's
an asian dude thing
an asian dude and an asian dad thing
anytime that that complex
or trope shows up in movies which trope
the i the father-son relationship
that [ __ ] kills me every i cry every
time like in tron and guardians of
galaxy 2 same thing the 5 if it's a
father-son trope knocks me out every
time anything terrible and tragic can
happen i won't [ __ ] cry the second
you go into some father-son [ __ ] i don't
know i just that's how that's how my dad
cried uh last week when he came to visit
so we were uh helping my dad get his
house cuz he moved here and um
you know having an asian dad you expect
him
to nothing is good enough everything
[ __ ] sucks what the [ __ ] are we doing
get it over with right that's the usual
like
what um that's the usual response i get
for everything like i might try this dim
sum it's so [ __ ] good oh this is hong
kong with 10 times better i'm like
whatever
yeah
it's always like that right so we take
them to the community we got a house in
he walks in he looks around i see his
eyes kind of like open up
and it's not like like super nice or
anything but it's like clean and i'm
like what do you think and he goes
oh it's beautiful in here i'm like oh
[ __ ] okay so like the vibes already feel
good [ __ ] positivity yeah so the
vibes felt good so i was like oh you
want to walk to like the uh
to a house that has the frames up so you
could kind of see
um like what the the floor plan would
look like he's like sure so we're
walking and we're just talking like
uh
like dad and son and it's way different
than usual and he's telling me he
watches all the vlogs because he gets to
see taika grow up and all that stuff and
then i told him i'm like you know it's
one of my favorite moments because we're
just sharing your favorite taco moments
what are you walking in a closet dad
so i told them i was like i was like
i was like you know it's one of my
favorite moments with taika he will
randomly grab me and look at me and go
you're the best papa in the world
and nothing else to compare
with you you'll see no one other dad
wait another time i told my dad that my
dad just started tearing up because he's
all like i sucked so hard
well maybe he's happy for me your dad
was a closet for many years or maybe
like
i think what made him tear is though
these are types of emotions he number
number one has never felt when he saw
taika do that to you know when i told
him this story
i think these are emotions he's never
felt always wanted but also doesn't know
how to articulate it yeah so by him
telling me and obviously my dad tried
his best even if by [ __ ] me in the
closet he still tried his best right so
i think by hit by me sharing this story
it hit him too
yeah like he was also because he raised
a good son who got that obviously yeah
so he started crying and i was i started
tearing up the nose maybe he's gotta
lock a [ __ ] kid in the closet and
then he'll buy you a house dude [ __ ]
my dad
any father-son trump that [ __ ] hits so
hard for asian people i mean i'm not
saying just asia i'm just saying like i
know consistently only asians okay the
galaxy two that was two asian dudes
[ __ ] star-lord and [ __ ]
what's this guy's name yeah luke
skywalker's dude who's asian as hell hey
you should be a break alexis i remember
um there was a scene at the end of blow
it's a drug dealing movie
he's like i cried so hard during i did
bro it caught me off [ __ ] guard and
it was a it was a it was a it was a
father-daughter situation
but the same i think you're pulling on a
heart string here because it was the
same situation where he [ __ ] up his
life
and then he was gonna do one last move
exit leave with the family all this
stuff right and his daughter never came
to visit him and he started going crazy
and and he kept thinking oh she's gonna
come and she never did
right right yeah yeah that was that was
rough spoiler alert guys spoiler alert i
know
but don't forget it sorry that still
doesn't count though you still have to
tell a story where you cried non
non-cinnamon related the last time i
actually cried like lost controlled like
painful cry was when my dog died
so then yeah got murdered by [ __ ]
coyotes and [ __ ] you know i that was
like a long like
uncontrollable weeks of crying like
somebody very i didn't even cry like
that when my grandma died and she
basically was more of a mother than my
mom was yeah because i spent more hours
with her right so like my grandma passed
i was like oh [ __ ]
damn
well
we were all waiting for that weren't we
you know but then the dog stuff was like
it felt like i lost a child man i know i
know that uncontrollable cry because
that was the last time i did two when my
dog died
it's crazy uncontrollable it's weird you
didn't know you had that type of emotion
in you no i was like when is this gonna
[ __ ] end bro it's like i'm gonna cry
right now yo was your dog also surprised
passing away yeah liver liver failure
she was five years old a little
chihuahua that i like traded dodger
tickets for in the back of the truck
so i named her dede for dodger dog uh
that's [ __ ] sick and then i was in
china and i was in china for like three
weeks and then my sister was trying to
reach me but she couldn't reach me
because the internet was bad so she
could so she reached my song
right and then mike was like yo your
sister is trying to reach out to me and
uh she never does so damn and i was like
oh [ __ ] something happened my [ __ ] was
overseas [ __ ] too i was in japan worse
and you feel so out of it
you're not there you're not there when
it happens way harder if you're not
there yeah
and i never knew that i would react in
such a way for an animal but i think
also
um that's the only thing i actually
loved and and put a lot of emotions into
like even you know in my personal
relationship at the time with with my
significant other or whatever i uh i
wasn't even fully 100
um vulnerable yeah so then like an
animal they they give you unconditional
love because they have to you know what
i mean like well it's not even human
love but then you know you project a lot
of that human emotion into an animal
right and then it's and it's safe
because you know
they can't cheat on you they can't [ __ ]
you over they can't do a lot of stuff so
then uh you you you give all of that to
one being that [ __ ] [ __ ] you up looking
like a guy who needs therapy
[Laughter]
i won't even cry my own mama dies but if
my pet rat goes
like that's unconditional love
i've heard that about you too i've heard
that you were never you're never quite
the same since you're since your dog
died i've heard that no like it was it
was a weird you know what though it's
like um
i think it's bittersweet because once
you
uh
don't have that anymore you're forced to
open up and maybe replace it by loving
people around you yeah you used to trust
people now yeah yeah so it came from
like isolation
dog teaching me how to be human and then
dog going away but then now
um set me up to start loving humans
again so it is a weird most beautiful
thing i've ever heard
this is my eyes are getting heavy right
now
today's video is brought to you by
curology i love curology man they sent
me or they sent us that that chapstick
pack
and i've been using it all over i leave
one in the truck and i leave one at uh
on my counter because it is drier out
here in vegas and it smells good it
smells really good and what's [ __ ]
cute is tycho's been using it too
because he gets little dry lips and he
likes the stick you know how it actually
like pushes out yeah so it's unlike any
other chapstick i've ever seen where you
have the cap and you twist it off and
sometimes you twist the whole thing off
this thing it's like a like a
switchblade you press it and it comes
out and you can take it out one hand
operation and i'll go like this like
when i went uh snowboarding with tyka
his lips got all dry put on his little
mouth and got all nice and moisturized
now at any moment did you feel like
using skin care products or lip balm
products or any of that stuff made you
feminine
never
when i was a kid yeah when you're a kid
yeah when i was a kid when i was younger
i was like oh man this is like girl
stuff but now you know like
women don't want dry
men they don't want nasty dudes they
don't want nasty crusty especially here
in las vegas super duper dry
that's not something that's cool and so
if you guys are kind of afraid of
getting in touch with your moisturized
side you know there's nothing wrong with
that i've been moisturizing myself shout
outs to curology for for sending me a
bunch of kids every single year you know
i've been using this product for about
two years now you know i've been getting
compliments like what do you use and i'm
like proud to say yeah curology baby
nothing else but just moisturize and
it's pretty cool because i get my own
personal formula from a licensed
dermatology provider and the process is
super easy you go online
you fill out a quick little survey you
tell them your goals you know i wanna
get rid of this acne i want to like make
sure that these wrinkles don't show you
know i want to do all this stuff i feel
so greasy i feel i got i got to boost
your eyes i don't know what to do you
know and especially someone like me like
i never really did skincare stuff before
curology hit me up you know i would go
to like
the pharmacy and look at all the
different lotions and products and i'm
like i don't know man i have no idea
where to start so i'm just gonna wash my
face with a bar of soap and then like
call it a day break google skincare and
the first image that pops up is a girl
taking a bath with milk i'm like i got
time for that kind of [ __ ] yeah that's
not for me no and
it's just there's too many options and i
just give up
but curology makes it super simple you
get your own personalized kit you know
they get your formula just for you your
goals they have a moisturizer in there
and a face wash and it's super duper
simple and easy to do so get started
with curology like we did go to
curology.com
off the record and you want to go there
you know why because you have a free
30-day trial that's an entire month you
get to try their products for free all
you gotta do is pay five dollars for the
shipping and handling that's
curology.com
off the record you can cancel at any
time and the prescription is subject to
consultation but last time
four years ago man
yeah really yeah
where we put my dog to sleep
and then that's i was there and then i
think i had my dog since uh my dog died
he was 16.
and then but then he just got to that
point where he just couldn't do anything
anymore by that time it's like herbert's
dog yeah look at just crawling can't
even walk
it was and then it was hard because my
dog was always really like jumpy so you
could never hug him
but then when he we put him asleep i had
to hug him to like hold him and that was
the first time i could ever hug him
without him jumping out and it was just
because he was too tired yeah it was
just done damn
hold on dude that's some deep [ __ ] man
[ __ ] dude i thought this is jk news yeah
what the [ __ ] is this just cry news bro
[ __ ] cry with a k right now
we're modern men all right we're careful
boys and modern men hey it's okay to
offset that it's okay to cry guys
[Laughter]
this this borderline doesn't count but i
cried way the [ __ ] harder for this
this is in 2001
and i cried at the ending of final
fantasy 10.
yeah that's so ryan dude but i like i
cried like the hardest i've ever cried
in my life was that the end of the game
like it was never it was the ending of
like the story and the way that it ends
was so freaking sad that like i so i was
playing all night right and then i had
to go to [ __ ] community college that
morning i get there and i go to my
[ __ ] speech class i'm failing
and the teacher is just like what
happened to ryan like he looks so sad
and she was asking my friends i wasn't
talking to anyone i'm like [ __ ] 18.
and she's just like she asked my friend
like is he okay like my friend's like
obviously 911 is affecting him a lot
he tells her he goes like i think he
broke up with his girl or something
and she comes up and she's like hey if
you don't want to do work today it's
like fun that's nice and she gave me a d
and i passed it what if it was like it's
worse than a breakup with my girlfriend
final fantasy i say that [ __ ] but that's
really all it was but my eyes were
[ __ ] wild jackie context you guys
gotta understand ryan is the biggest
final fantasy fan i've ever met in my
entire life but that's like lifelong
[ __ ] though and he level seriously
recreated final fantasy and digitized
pixelated form with all of his friends
even kendra's were in it too he like
remade the game
like he's [ __ ] die hard he knows how
to play every song from it like it's
intense it's to an unhealthy degree but
basically that was the saddest thing
that happened to you in 2001 uh a
significant year for i think a lot of
people
space odyssey that was a tough movie too
yeah space honestly thank you but that's
the place my mind goes because every
like for some reason every every time i
date someone new and that girl asks like
when's the last time you cry i've never
seen you cry and my mind always goes to
that and i never want to share it
because it's
so [ __ ] lame
but it's real though it's real oh i
remember a [ __ ] another time i cried
um
uh
i had a one-night stand and it was
[ __ ] like i got damn man i [ __ ] it
was good
it was like a lie oh damn man it was
[ __ ] good not like i didn't i wasn't
expecting you you over performed yeah
you were quiet how hard you smashed that
[ __ ]
that wasn't even no like i didn't even
try because oh [ __ ] i'll last three
minutes today
what the [ __ ] noise today yeah
he broke the four minute mile like that
was the equivalent i did a perfect
performance it was given to me no i like
no it was like i liked it so much right
it was so good i was single right
but then i had a crush on somebody so i
felt like i cheated on my crush
i was like why must i be so [ __ ]
honorable and [ __ ] oh
interesting you're loyal dude last time
but the [ __ ] was so good and then she
had surprise breasts like it was
surprised you know like you know when
someone's like they don't look big and
then when they take off their clothes it
flops and you're like wow wow
and then you have sex because during
that time you can't think of nothing
else but that and you're legally allowed
to because you're single it's true but
illegally
your inner heart
belongs to someone else thanks to
legislation yeah underground
this person i never even met before i'm
hearing these guys stories i'm like oh
man i'm hearing your story
did you think about the the girl you
crush on during sex with this other girl
oh you put your crush's face on her face
no no no no no i came
and then and saw and i came right
and then um yeah and then i was worried
no she left the hotel right the next day
she left the hotel and then like i was
facetiming um the girl i had a crush on
right took a shower while talking to her
and then as i was showering she
masturbated and then a part of me just
felt like oh you son of a [ __ ] dude
wait wait wait you son of a [ __ ] what
did she masturbate was sitting again you
were face timing and we
[ __ ] okay
and i felt so dirty because the day
before i had go in my hotel room and
then the next day i'm facetiming with
the girl that i'm um loyal to in my and
just like it's like just yeah i know oh
yeah i get all right
just the masturbation parts through me i
i missed it
it was killing me inside
because of the guilt so talking on the
phone and then and as i'm talking to her
on my phone i start crying and i'm just
crying and and i'm just so
guilty the shower jack and all she's
jokingly subscribed after i come after i
come you told so you told her no no
that's why it was killing me inside
but she knows now
did you tell her why you were crying no
it was something i bullshitted
i it was it was something else right i
know i [ __ ] about something else i
think that was the part that really hurt
me because like i wanted to tell her
yeah i wanted you know cause like at the
end of the day like it's i'm single
right but then like i'm really i didn't
know that i was that interested in
someone i was talking to online you know
so like there's like six or seven girls
around the world that have phone sex
with him while he was in the shower
right now that are questioning [ __ ] like
[ __ ]
like i thought our photos were special i
guess not that special right they're
like he did cry at the end of mine but
that was a different story like was i
the one with the surprise titties
they're all checking do they come out
are they coming out the right way oh
nick no
when were your crime boy real quick the
last time i like i hard cried like
balling
was i was like 2019
i went to singapore
with my family and my girl and i was the
first time we were engaged first time i
seen my family in singapore since i was
like like seven or eight oh wow and i
was 27.
so
i'm seeing all my family family i
haven't seen in so long um
and i'm just spending all the time with
everybody and
for some reason we're flying home and it
was there was a lot of
yeah there was it was just seeing a lot
of family and a little drama here and
there family drama and [ __ ] but for some
reason i just on the way home i just
felt like
like i just needed to cry like i just
felt so overwhelmed with like in a train
no no we're flying home oh in the
airplane and they're playing see there's
something about the [ __ ] airplane
that make people cry dude and i just
felt like very fortunate for some reason
but i also felt really sad with some
[ __ ] that happened on the trip whatever
but i just felt really overwhelmed with
emotions to the point where i just don't
i just started bawling and i just
couldn't help it i was just like crying
i'm like crying into my girl's arms bro
like and i'm like sobbing i'm like loud
crying honestly i understand why you're
crying she knew she was right and i'm
[ __ ] like this was she knew but you
didn't know kind of
well well in a way where it was just
like it was just an emotional like it
was just i don't know what there was a
little there was stuff that happened
where we kind of had some issues like
talking up like did you suppress like
emotions yeah for sure for sure there
was a lot of like a lot of stressful
situations but also
it felt very complicated because a lot
of issues with like my immediate family
but
felt so much love and and and like um
rekindling relationships with family i
haven't seen in years like my whole life
and so that was like really conflicting
and i felt really happy that i went but
i also felt really sad because a lot of
[ __ ] happened from that trip
and i just remember i was like crying
for like 15 minutes bro like to the
point where i was like exhausted like
you know wow and it just felt really
[ __ ] weird but it was uh yeah it was
it was that was the only time i like
where i really felt like
completely overwhelmed like i felt like
an adrenaline dump like i just was like
so tired afterwards that's that dog
death cry yeah and and honestly i could
equate that so like when my golden
retriever died when i was like like like
12 13 years old and i'm sobbing over
like my dead like my [ __ ] dead dog
you know but
besides that like i haven't really hard
cried in a really long time like that
you have to put your dog to sleep or
something no we found our dog dead oh
that's the worst yeah dude and i don't
want no dogs man i gotta pick up dog
[ __ ] and cry
this was sad man [ __ ] bro why did you
guys want to talk about crying [ __ ] i
don't know well we you know we're trying
to make it everyone crying talk about
this if i
mine was recent mine was pretty recent
right so um you know uh
i
for years tried to get my family to
cryptocurrency stuff of course
and uh you know and i'll be i'll be just
completely 100 right so
um my family uh made fun instead
and like really i thought it was mean
yeah that was a little vicious in fact
it was like they went in like yeah might
as well set my money that's where you
get the roasting from
yeah yeah thanks guys might as well set
my money on fire all that kind of stuff
right and so and for me i and and also
there was one particular christmas too
where i was telling my my little brother
who ended up my little brother kenny who
ended up going with me on this entire
crypto journey and he's done very very
well
and um
i remember telling him i was like hey
dude uh crypt is not over like people i
know like everyone thinks it's over and
stuff but it's not over
and if you buy like
now if you really take it seriously
right now you're gonna change your life
and he um and i was saying this to
everybody there but they were all
treating me like i was a leper like my
own family
which sucks you know because you love
them and you're you're there to see them
and they they wouldn't even address me
like look at me anything it was weird
but my brother
wait they actually thought you're some
like cultist yeah you join a cult or
something like can i ask you a question
about that like when you're talking to
your family about that [ __ ] and they're
reacting a certain way does that ever
make you kind of like second guess or
doubt at all no i just well it's not
even that it's not even that i i i was
like i know what i'm doing promise you
if you listen to me but they wouldn't
even just do that or even respect what
my passion is that's it so so
so then um
you know fast forward to now
um or even just like when i started
crypto corner
you know there are people who you could
argue who are strangers right who i
don't know in real life but
they give me more love than my own
family does because
you know
doing getting into crypticorn they
change their lives and they they let me
know how they change their lives and
like hi i'm 25 years old or i'm 24 years
old i just bought a house
because i know steve green and i and i
i trusted him and i'm like you can't see
so many people but but and then like
there's
several people who are millionaires
right now and they're like dude i
wouldn't have been here if i didn't if i
didn't listen to you right and stuff
like that just it you know makes it's
the opposite of feeling like i'm the
king of the world it's it's a very
humbling thing because you're like man i
you know it's crazy to think that um
you've had an effect on people but
really i'm just so proud of you that you
took that because i've seen so many
people that i've given the info to get
affected by so many other people that
they that they meet who tell them no no
that's all scam don't worry or they
listen to their dad who's like oh no i
just read it on on cnbc it's a scam so
don't worry it's a scam
got you right and so so those people
fall by the wayside but then
you know i'm getting love from people
that i don't really quote know but then
i feel like i know them and i'm getting
more love from them than i do the people
in my own circle yeah and so yeah i you
know i was on a on a particular day
where a couple people hit the million
um and they told me and they were very
nice and sent me a bunch of nice things
about it um i
i broke down on me and nikki's podcast
at the end of it because we were talking
about how the year went and stuff and
yeah i just finally let it all go
because i've been piling up for so long
and stuff and uh it was really good for
me it was really good for me because i
i'm a person who allows
those little moments to build and i use
them to propel me and it really has been
great for me i i'm actually very
grateful like i like i'm i'm grateful
that i got bullied as a kid too because
it made me
who i am today like the same way yeah
you're you're a revenge porn kind of guy
i am yeah i i like to i like to beat
people who think i'm wrong about
something and i and i you have to wake
up every day and do the work though so
so like but i need that little bit of a
thing it's a little slight that you gave
me that you got a little david saw in
you dude yeah hey we're buds
he's done really well uh so but that's
what i mean like it's it's um yeah so i
i lost it over that and it was great it
was good for me but that's [ __ ] crazy
though yeah that's deep yeah because you
let them you let them in they're
vulnerable to them yeah dude that's why
doc just love a dog [ __ ] your family
anyway thanks guys good talk
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you